within recent years it's almost
customary for most games to have some
sort of multiplayer feature and
retirement within the contents of the
game some games like call of duty and
battlefield are expected to have
multiplayer in them as both have had
multiplayer for years but games like far
cry bioshock and dead space all had
multiplayer too
you may not have even known about them
as they were only in about one entry in
the series then dropped as the
developers focus more on the story side
of the game rather than long-term
multiplayer but they did exist for quite
some time plus these modes weren't
exactly well received by the general
public as much as i want to disagree
with that statement as i still believe
far cry 3 multiplayer was criminally
underrated and i'll hold that stance
till the day i die regardless assassin's
creed is just like these three past
games we briefly mentioned a game series
with a brief multiplayer introduction
then it disappears a couple entries
later with no expected return but i
think assassin's creed has the ability
to continue its multiplayer in some
fashion because the uniqueness of the
series so what exactly happened to
assassin's creed multiplayer anyway
and what does the future of the game
look like let's find out so assassin's
creed is a
13-year franchise going back as far as
2007 with the first release of
assassin's creed 1 with its newest
introduction ac valhalla in 2020 within
that time frame ubisoft would make 12
main entries which are not counting its
spin-off console platformers and mobile
games
case in point there's a lot of games
within the franchise but only five of
these had multiplayer features
four had legitimate pvp gameplay that
being brotherhood revelations ac3 and
black flag with unity being the outlier
of the five is but doesn't have a
traditional pvp multiplayer experience
it does have cooperative play black flag
released back in 2013 with unity
releasing a year later in 2014 so it's
been around seven to eight years since
assassin's creed had a multiplayer game
mode of some kind
the series in recent years went under
many dramatic changes shifting to a more
rpg style of play but neither of these
three games have multiplayer in them
with the exception of valhalla which
does allow you to recruit other players
character made vikings into your army
but i wouldn't really call that
multiplayer more of an online feature
for a semi-long explanation of assassin
creed multiplayer it's divided into solo
and team modes that being deathmatch
wanted and assassinate as well as
artifact assault manhunt and domination
deathmatch wanted an assassinate have
small details to differentiate them
from their other counterparts but the
core concept is the same a free-for-all
game mode where you pursue the other
players while other players pursue you
they differ in some ways like wanted
giving you the targets outright whereas
assassinate you have to find them
yourself
the actual gameplay is similar to the
respective games combat systems minus of
course the common sword fighting you may
see in single player you can only kill
the person you are pursuing and only
stun the person targeting you all within
10 minute games
the team game modes have more variety
between them with artifact assault being
your typical capture the flag game mode
and manhunt being a 4v4 team version of
wanted with one team attacking and the
other hiding who then switch after the
round is up while maybe the generic game
modes you would expect in any
multiplayer game it's because of the
mechanics of the game that make them
interesting again
playing capture the flag in typical fps
games is nothing new and slightly
changed due to the mechanics of that
game call of duty and halo capture the
flag are similar in some ways but at its
core both games are just first person
shooters of course there's many
differences between them but you get my
point
assassin's creed has stealth and parkour
mechanics that make it feel refreshing
again now having to watch rooftops or
groups of people for the enemy or on the
other side of the coin and waiting until
the right moment to take the artifact as
someone could be sneaking in the
objective waiting after the game you get
xp which can increase your level this
comes with the game's awards that branch
anywhere from cosmetics to in-game
abilities there is a load of
customization in the game as there is a
base cast of 15 characters all with
separate cosmetics to unlock as even
though the colors may be the same
between
two characters they're unlocked at
different times depending on who you
play
each character has a costume three gear
pieces a color die and a relic to wear a
new character and that's just the style
tab as there's the separate head
moves and weapons tab all with their
respective subcategories meaning there
is a plethora of cosmetics with the
likelihood that yours won't look the
same as other people's but because the
nature of the game modes there is a
permanent single pick on all gamemodes
so sometimes somebody may take your
preferred assassin which means having a
backup character so it's going to cost
you a lot of credits to make
multiple characters some may see this as
a scummy way to increase
profits but it makes sense with the way
the game modes are played plus other
games have done the system before with
not too much backlash from it besides
the cosmetics are the actual in-game
abilities that can range anywhere from
changing your disguise to outright
murdering anyone near you without even
giving them a chance to retaliate
a typical loadout consists of two
abilities one ranged weapon two perks
and a killer loss streak with the 15
abilities 5 ranged weapons 13 perks and
12 bonuses you can mix and match to fit
the game mode or preferred playstyle
whether it's using a poison dart from
afar or stunning pursuers in close
quarters
after surpassing another level
requirement you can craft these
abilities which enhances certain points
of the ability itself like increased
duration or how much of that equipment
you can store on you making it even more
effective
after the game also comes of sturgo
credits these are unlocked by playing
games with its alternative being ec
or your detail credits which is bought
using real money if circle credits are
your typical in-game credits you'd see
in any other video game they unlock all
the items in the game
but ec can allow you to buy most things
that otherwise would be too expensive
with abstergo credits and also allow you
to bypass the level restriction on any
item you see as you usually have to
level up to unlock it then purchase it
with the credits
this is an oversimplification of the
assassin creed multiplayer in its most
basic format but what amplifies the
experience of multiplayer are those
mechanics of the game we previously
discussed
the parkour and the stealth that is
present in single player in single
player you are a unique player in the
game's world you're able to hide in hey
or blend in with the crowd as you see
fit you normally don't have to worry
about if people beneath you can see you
as the game usually isn't programmed to
allow that or vice versa there isn't
assassins hiding up in the rafters
waiting to pounce on you but in
multiplayer there is and i've always
felt that to be a strong suit of the
franchise's multiplayer just using the
basic mechanics of the game with no
weird tactics or quirks makes it feel
fresh
for some contrast i'll reference call of
duty again as an example
in its single player you either shoot
people from up close or afar
and the single player everyone is a
soldier so it's roughly the same combat
when it's translated into multiplayer
with assassin's creed you are a unique
entity in the world so when multiplayer
makes everyone that unique entity of
being an assassin it changes the
gameplay drastically and like we stated
before
these changes due to the game's basic
mechanics make typical game modes
entertaining again
a typical match of any of the game modes
see you using those mechanics you
learned in single player hiding in a
group
using lifts to escape throwing money or
smoke to distract crowds or hiding on
rooftops and stalking your prey it's so
simple
yet so fun when you put a lobby together
of people who can do the same thing
of course the question still remains
even with the praise the multiplayer and
assassin's creed gets
what happened to it in the overall
community consensus it's agreed upon
that it was due to a high skill curve
and ubisoft's attempts to put more
effort into the single player experience
assassin's creed is a hard game to fully
master especially in multiplayer being
able to hide and go against multiple
people at once as well as the precise
timing of actually stunning the player
versus contesting the kill can be quite
tough for a new player to grasp
and when the lobby is filled with people
who have that knowledge it can be quite
discouraging to continue playing couple
that with the various cheese mechanics
players have exploited like stun locking
people and manhunt as well as the
ability to get ahead of some people
simply by paying for the future
abilities it can be a tiresome
experience
that part wasn't meant as a hate piece
towards it but more addressing some
issues that players can encounter as it
can ruin some players experiences who
weren't too keen on the multiplayer mode
to begin with but gave it a shot anyway
out of curiosity that are met with the
aforementioned tactics i encountered
these exact scenarios only a couple
times in the tens of hours i played
multiplayer whether it was recently or
back in 2014 so they aren't a common
occurrence which is a relief but they do
still exist
the main problem that halts many cries
for a multiplayer mode is the question
of development time i'll go into this a
little bit more when we discuss ac unity
but because the developers have a
certain time period to finish the game
the more modes and external features
they add the less time they individually
get more attention that's most likely
why ubisoft stopped making multiplayer
was to focus
on the single player experience and make
it extremely fleshed out and enjoyable
and judging from the perception of the
recent entries it seems like it has
worked as some have argued these are
some of the best assassin's creed games
to ever exist
if multiplayer isn't your thing however
ac unity is the only current game so far
with cooperative play
it applies the details we talked about
before but instead of multiple assassins
fighting each other it's multiple
assassins teaming up together making
large scale fights not an outnumbered
match but makes them more even
ac unity actually makes the assassins
feel like a group
too many instances in the main story
it's the main character who is a part of
the assassins going up against countless
templar leaders alone or with the
occasional help of a side character who
is only aligned with them and not
actually fighting with them
unity's co-op actually makes it seem
like there are other assassins in the
organization and not just
you unity's cooperative missions are
weaved into the story as there are
people in the different districts
throughout the game that provide the
player with co-op missions but anything
you use in single-player can be
transferred into co-op like outfits
weapons and abilities
so nothing is lost by doing this with
multiplayer in the previous titles all
the content was earned for that mode all
the outfits abilities credits etc rover
all for multiplayer but with the co-op
in unity you can progress your character
using these co-op missions the co-op
missions clearly had lots of effort put
into them as these aren't just simple
assassination missions but multi-step
cooperative missions with unique end
goal in mind for an example let's look
at one of the better co-op missions in
the game the tournament
upon starting the mission we're
presented with a unique cutscene
showcasing our target
and the small story behind it for this
mission our target is general marcor who
is responsible for slaughtering people
all across france because of these
actions he's heavily loved by the
templars my core and his close allies
were conspiring a coup to end the
revolution faster but one of our
associates alexandre dumas has blended
in with the group and supplied us with
this information
marcor is using the upcoming tournament
so he can select more warriors for the
coup
our goal here is quite simple
assassinate markor so we can [ __ ] the
templars and prevent the coup but
getting there won't be as easy as only
the winners of the tournament are
allowed inside to meet with him so we're
gonna have to work around this
first is finding the identification
papers so we can enter for a chance to
win the tournament
each player needs one of these and can
be found by stealing them off select
guards or finding the papers at nearby
outposts once we have the papers we have
to participate in an obstacle course
people who succeed are allowed in the
tournament this required our team to
capture all 34 flags in the course
and afterwards we can then start the
tournament the tournament has some
simple rules
everyone gets a flag we need to raise
the other four flags without having ours
lowered which is unfortunate considering
the fact that there's five teams and
four
corners so we get the middle of the
arena as our base raising them is quite
the challenge with the massive amount of
enemies at the start with more that pile
and later once the original group is
dealt with
once complete we get our meeting with
mark core but thanks to our previous
antics of killing lots of guards marcor
became worried and not only is he deeper
in the building but he has more guards
on alert as opposed to this being easier
if we didn't get alerted
this adds small layers of depth to the
quest we kill the conspirators
kill marcor and leave ending the mission
this is one of the many unique quests in
the game
and some have more or less in-depth
mechanics than the mission we just
discussed but one of the benefits of
these missions is unique items only
acquired by completing these missions as
well as the ability to do these solo now
obviously not every one of them is going
to be a walk in the park
for instance collecting all 34 flags and
the obstacle course solo would be a
large pain but it's not impossible to do
so but considering how many co-op
missions there are compared to how many
that would be hard to complete solo it's
quite possible you could do almost all
of them the problem this brings though
is a lack of increased depth and
difficulty
most of not all the missions have a
system in place where if you are
undetected all the way through you can
earn more bonus rewards but it's not a
requirement
in a mission where you're supposed to
sneak into a building grab a key
steal a notebook and rescue someone you
can go loud throughout the entire way
through and get it done just as well if
not faster than sneaking around
besides not getting the extra rewards
there is the occasional gameplay change
like in the tournament mission we
discuss but most times it's a slap on
the wrist via a quote from one of the
npcs which is practically nothing
as you can see from the gameplay we were
supposed to assassinate marcor with the
game assuming we would at least attempt
stealth but that didn't happen as we all
walked in through a window
smoked the room killed everyone and left
immediately i do understand why this is
the case though as having a failed
condition like being detected in a
mission would make that almost
uncompletable in a public game with no
communications but with the way the
systems and the most recent games are i
don't think they need to worry about
these unfortunate scenarios in the newer
entries in the series they haven't done
away with stealth exactly but it's
definitely taken a backseat compared to
its predecessors going for a more rpg
feel of a game as opposed to a stealth
game
because of the emphasis on rpg elements
like rarity and power systems
ubisoft has an excellent cooperative
experience on its hands in the form of
cooperative missions like in unity with
valhalla's mechanics or just straight up
cooperative dungeons like raids with
other players
it's a very typical idea that most games
have adopted but it can work as long as
they put the time into it
one obvious issue of having a co-op or
multiplayer mode is less time on the
single-player experience making both not
as good as they could be but assuming
they either have a dedicated team to
work on the multiplayer or
only one team working on both but are
given enough development time to flush
out both experiences
it could be an excellent time waster for
players who want to play more assassin's
creed but don't want to start new
playthroughs as they may find it boring
or repetitive
many companies have taken this approach
and succeeded but with the addition of a
separate company or team that means more
employees and
more money being spent by ubisoft to
fund the team so it's definitely a
double-edged sword there was an
interview with chief creative officer on
assassin's creed who talked about
wanting multiplayer back in the
franchise and said that with the current
modern technology they could have a
hundred players in the game at one time
assuming of course they removed the npcs
as that would be quite the performance
it who knows how far this development
idea has gone as this article was
published around 2018 before odyssey's
release so it probably won't be for a
long time until we see another
multiplayer co-op feature return again
as we wind down to the outro of the
video let me know your thoughts on the
video as a whole do you still play
assassin's creed was the multiplayer or
co-op
fun to you do you also want it back
anything like that feel free to share it
in the comments down below
as usual with this stuff like the video
if you enjoyed and subscribe for more
analysis and discussion videos on video
games in the near future i got plans to
release another one in the coming weeks
about another ubisoft series that was
also casually name dropped at the
beginning of this video
with that take care everyone and i'll
see you next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you